would we trust somebody who is stirring
up these violent feelings who is
pointing fingers scapegoating making a
joke about a violent attack on Paul
Pelosi why would you trust that person
to have power over you your family your
business your community
not sure what candidate she was
referring to today but I'm pretty sure
uh GOP came out right away to denounce
the violence against Paul Pelosi and in
fact just last night it was a GOP
candidate Don bulldock who had someone
try to punch him Lee zeldon attacked on
stage so let's face it all political
candidates on both sides have faced some
possible crazies coming out after them
of course and look we live in a hyper
polarized time and and big Tech and
social media have done strange things to
all of us uh so nobody's hands are
totally clean here but it's like
basically the ultimate irony that she's
talking to Joy Reed as she's talking
about inflammatory remarks and
everything else Joy Reid who every day I
mean the whole
Drive of
to call half of the country racist and
white supremacists and Donald Trump said
Nazi and extreme Mega Republicans it's
like look how how simply you could flip
the language on them they say we're
saying all these mean things about them
well if you keep calling half the
country Nazis and evil Mega Republicans
are you putting a Target on their back I
mean just using their own Logic the
answer would be yes I'm not even saying
that's the case but by their logic
they're doing exactly what they claim we
are doing so uh Hillary it's like lady
you said that Donald Trump was an
illegitimate president were you were you
uh not abiding by the election last time
are you an election denier how come Joy
didn't ask her that it's only okay when
they do it of course and um again when
it's Democratic privilege ah it's
amazing right but we even have uh the
mainstream media this was an interesting
headline at least they're being honest a
little bit uh The Washington Post points
out the reality that the GOP is more
enthusiastic about Trump than Democrats
are about Biden I mean there's talk that
him and Kamala should just even and say
we are not going to run at all and it's
I don't think they're going to do that
but there's calls for it already
no look Joe Biden whether he realizes it
or not he's going to be the sacrificial
lamb here because obviously he's too old
and muddled and everything else to run
for a second term even though he's
pretending that he is and Kamala and
Pete and all of them are pretending that
they'll support him but they are going
to need to blame someone for this and by
the way even in a good year even if
things were going well right now
generally speaking the president's the
incumbent president's party does very
poor in the off years the fact that we
have so many bad markers right now is
just adding to it so they're gonna have
to push Joe out I suspect that either
Hillary or Barack Obama will basically
be on a 60 Minutes interview and say you
know Joe does seem like he's lost the
step and next thing you know all of the
media will be saying it and they'll
figure out a way to put him out to
pasture and then they will move on to
whether it's Gavin Newsom or Hillary I
mean the list is not very impressive
um but they're in a lot of trouble they
should be in trouble and I would say uh
Bianca I know you're in Florida as well
as I am the the Freedom Movement starts
here you know Florida basically is
exporting freedom and if we can make
America more like Florida we won't have
to worry about the Joe bidens and the
joy reads and the rest of them you're
right well the smart folks from
California like us and some New Yorkers
you know the Exodus did come here so I
think people are catching on to the vibe
and what's happening um I did want to
get your talk uh your take on this this
is really enjoyable so we have Elon Musk
over at Twitter now and you know he's
trying to charge users for verification
on the platform and AOC uh and him kind
of got into a Twitter war yesterday she
was calling him out saying LMAO a
billionaire earnestly trying to sell
people on the idea that free speech is
eight dollars a month to which he like
shot back and I love this because she
does sell merch her 58 dollar sweatshirt
uh she's so hypocritical I think she
even had another one that was like 300 a
few years ago Dave do you remember that
it was like tax Rich super grotesque
tax the risk the rich while she's at the
Met Gala in something like what was it
like a thirty thousand dollar gown while
you know she's a designer hadn't paid
her taxes it was such a debacle I'm
shocked I'm shocked and all of the
people that were serving them the
servants still had to wear masks but
there's a beautiful thing happening
right now because Elon Musk look Elon
Musk is not a traditional conservative
Elon Musk until a few months ago had
never voted Republican that's what he
tells us and then he finally voted for
Myra Flores now that he's moved to Texas
instead of California because he wanted
to escape for tax reasons and a whole
bunch of other reasons so the idea that
they're trying to pin him as this evil
maniacal right-wing scary racist
conservative capitalist whatever it's
like man you guys just want nobody to be
on your side because if Elon Musk is not
moderate enough for you who I have no
doubt is extremely moderate on social
issues and is and again is not a
traditional Republican right if he's not
good enough for you AOC if he's the guy
you want to pick fights with well then
congratulations because you're just
going to keep purging more and more
people to our side and and frankly I'm
I'm fine with that so maybe I hope aoc's
not watching this I highly doubt she's
watching because AOC watch news max in
the afternoon I don't know no I mean
we've invited to have her on it would be
quite entertaining
um but I don't think I think she's too
afraid of that you know it'd be it'd be
an interesting conversation with her uh
hey Dave as always we appreciate you
coming on we love your Insight it's
always a good time and next week you'll
be back with John
sounds good see you soon all right have
a good weekend if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell